food trends and who better to share some
of the culinary trends that we're seeing
in 2022 than our friends at the
cosmopolitan and joining us now is their
executive director of food and beverage
brian feiler thanks for joining us today
i appreciate it i love what you do at
the cosmopolitan because you guys are
always ahead of the game you guys are
always ahead of the trends and you're
going to tell us what is big this year
now first of all i walk in here in the
kitchen and i say
is that a donut sandwich that i see in
the pan here what is going on it is so
you know today we want to talk about
some of the food trends that happen here
in uh 2022 and also what we're seeing at
the cosmopolitan in las vegas so what
you have here is our monte cristo from
district one at sliders and brew one of
the themes this year that we're seeing
is grab-and-go breakfast right okay but
they want the good stuff and they want
the good stuff so this monte cristo here
i mean this is a donut it's got some
applewood ham on it a little bit of
havarti cheese we griddle that on a
house made donut that we make fresh
every day and then what we're going to
do is we're going to finish it just with
a little bit of the raspberry preserves
oh my goodness and a little bit of
powdered sugar this is not your typical
monte cristo so you do this right nice
and healthy and then you finish that
with a vietnamese iced coffee oh
and that's a great grab and go breakfast
you guys always elevate things you don't
make it just the typical way you always
kick it up a notch that's why i love the
cosmopolitan so much and district has
their own coffee brand as well cool kids
which is really amazing as well
some of the other trends that we're
seeing is alternative dairy products
inside grab-and-go drinks so i've got
juice standard here we've got three of
them so there's a bee happy here right
and chocolate is also one of those
things that's very popular i love the
juice standard and i love that you can
mix those if you want to turn it into a
cocktail absolutely you can mix it up
there too not that i've done that over
there before but anyway so cashew
butters coconut bases things like that
brazilian nuts all healthy things that
are helping but alternative you know um
methods to to the dairy so not just your
regular cow milk okay i hear spices big
this
fun here we're going to is something
from bongbaar which is by momofuku so
we're going to move these two things out
of the way all right and then i'm going
to have you help me actually okay let's
do it so what you're going to do we're
going to take these these are our fold
ups so these are just little mini like
pitas if you will okay okay we're going
to take two of them and i want you to
take some of this beautiful spicy
eggplant so this is just hard roasted
eggplant with some chilies some vibrant
thai basil and some lime juice okay okay
just put it in here yep and you're going
to put some of that in there
oh this smells delicious and i'm going
to come behind and i'm going to top it
with a little bit of our toppings here
and so
spicy is big grab-and-go is spicy's big
grab-and-go is big another one that's
really big is uh cocktails but bottled
pre-bottled for you so if you look here
superfrico does a whole routine of them
which is just really delicious and so
i've got a couple of their martini
versions here
this one
delicious so the way you name this and
i'll let you guys figure that one out is
you got to get your first pet's name and
then the street you grew up on
fluffy i-15 that's it
who grew up on the iphone somebody grew
up on the i-15 there so that's how they
named it okay
so check these out so we're finishing
these with a little cabbage a little bit
of pickled onions
finish it with a little bit of lime
juice there and that is spicy it's vegan
it's fragrant it's delicious it's just i
love it i think it's one of my favorites
and this is another grab-and-go too now
they're grabbing at the same time so
it's all about convenience it's all
about spies and it's all about
deliciousness you can get all of these
amazing concoctions and food trends like
i said they elevate everything at the
cosmopolitan you can't go wrong thank
you so much thank you for having me
appreciate it